all right Sinjin or should I call you
Fabio have you ever heard of Fabio you
have this great hair let me send you in
Fabio long skin so you are about to be
on 90 day fiancé this show is huge are
you prepared for the fans so I am NOT
personally paid for the fans I'm kind of
a whelmed where I'm staying right now I
don't know what's gonna happen so I lose
now okay so you're from South Africa yes
you come here to the US where do you
head to I actually went to Colchester
which is actually my last name my last
name is Colchester I land up in
Colchester what state is that
Connecticut so what was that change like
for you will we see you go through some
stuff this is syndromes first time in
the States it's real doubt it's reality
to figure out you'll see me go through
some pretty rough nut stuff for some
pretty rough so it's like a whole real
whole new experience for me it's a you
know taxes are high that's what I'm
saying how dramatic did it get I got
pretty dramatic like it got so real that
times always questionable to what I was
doing in the States
yeah when you I don't have that full so
me feeling
what do you mean by that what I mean by
that is like when you question is this
is the right decision whether this is
the right decision to come here or not
like you you come you fly halfway across
the world to figure out it's a love of
work and when you question it I think
always be a possibility but the question
came up quite a quite a couple of times
did the love work who knows good answer
I mean I'm pushing you on that but we
don't want to spoil it but we do see you
arguing over a prenup think what's good
about a prenup as you decide like the
terms that sounds great well it's done
in happy positive I'm not signing over
did you sign that prenup you know that
prenup I don't know you know yeah we are
what's right in the trailer so we're
definitely gonna hear more about it oh
yeah
well so you come here to the state had
you watch 90-day fiance before at all I
have actually it was a program button my
mom so me and mommy had some lovey
watching the Nunda fiance and then when
I made Tanya I was like hey watch these
people these crazy people and suppose
okay well I mean a lot of people get
accused of coming on the show for fame
did you come on the show for fame I did
not come on the show her fame so that's
like now we were like with the biting
with the cameras and she sent the email
and boom hello you wanna do it well look
people are gonna see what happens with
you they might have reactions or
misconceptions what would you tell those
people if they have any major opinions
on what they see with you so out of
those people you know watch out be ready
it's gonna be drama fold impact action
it's all real it's all [ __ ] it's how we
deal with with 90 days you to get
married in such a short period so yeah
it's gonna be crazy
anything you would have done differently
now that it's all been filmed and all
that I know nothing differently maybe
suelo less
we're gonna have to bleep a few things
in this interview I'm a [ __ ] of that and
what can you tease just overall about
the journey you guys go on is it drama
is it passion is it immaturity what can
we expect I would say it's drama passion
immaturity false precision crazy it's
all of diva
[Music]